[Music]
and welcome back to another exciting
episode of the careful careful boys
cryptos doing [ __ ] cool right now
except for me we are speaking of joe we
are in
what has been constantly spoken about
whether uh directly or indirectly in the
best cycle of the bull run here for this
crypto market there's bull run and
there's bear run but there's also apron
what's apron yeah explain this to me
he's speaking he's speaking
language right now straight line up or
what yeah how everything's about to go
ballistic and we and we've been on this
show before and we've talked about
different cryptos and we you know we've
got a little meta with some of our fans
stuff like that and anybody who's
falling to crypto corner with steve
steve and or joe steve and or joe and or
me when i've lost [ __ ] point is
you know
the
the depth of how much we care
but to get relatable to get serious
what the [ __ ] does that actually mean
when
when you succeed in crypto and what are
you going to do with it what's the game
plan some of you guys are out there i'm
gonna do what i did last time where i
went from a million dollars to 15 000.
but also at the same time i think um
investing in crypto has been part of
like the norm
like millennial society and younger
where i see a lot of people talking
about crypto trading nfts and all that
so i feel like at this bull run there's
actually going to be a lot of people
that are benefiting from it can i can i
can wealth transfer can i take a one
half step back real quick and just talk
about more of a macro concept of
investments and the normalization of
that right because obviously growing up
uh investments not a new concept
everybody wants to get into it from my
mind from my basic ass you know like
just trying to figure it out and not
being born into a rich family i think
about things like your retirement fund
your old ass [ __ ] yeah getting into real
estate even older [ __ ] and honestly
anything after that is uh not super
quick to be accessible i didn't even
think about investing until like
30 or later because you just hear about
[ __ ] real estate stocks whatever i
wasn't [ __ ] boring ass [ __ ] but i
think kids these days like crypto has a
sexy element to it right like not
controlled by the institutions it's
decentralized and then so like there's a
lot more kids
even like they don't even know that
though look i love you brother i love
you but i think a lot of kids are like i
know there's some do right but i'm
talking about the the greater masses
unfortunately don't even understand that
not 30 and above but i think all the
young cats from 20 to 30. it seems like
the norm now we're like okay cool i work
at mcdonald's i'll play ten percent into
some crypto yeah but right but the
cryptos they pick are like some garbage
[ __ ] though that's what i'm saying but
as far as like from what i see i'm a
very casual crypto guy right well from
when i see when people that get into
crypto especially like young people it
seems like it's more about the quick
exactly it's such a mistake meme called
the return that's why she will pump the
way that it did that's why doge pumped
the way that it did yes
but you're not gonna make the long
lasting gains like dude if you were just
hanging out in my tara luna like i've
been talking about the whole year um
you you killed it compared to everybody
you know maybe damned so many people
uh but except for maybe solana like
there's like one maybe who got away from
me right solana solana crushed crushed
it gotta admit crushed it definitely
still don't see why personally because i
understand why luna is going to be huge
and why the lunar rewards are getting
crazier right now and for all of us who
are staking luna it's like getting even
sicker but but as far as like um where a
lot of the younger people who are coming
into crypto and they get excited about
it unfortunately it's about the
intermediate like or like the quick
quick quick gains and i think that
that's no different than just buying
scratchers at the [ __ ]
like there's gonna be a lot
losers love do you agree with that but i
i do a of
think one thing that i'm like what's
kind of cool is even taking the first
step into investing which is the concept
of like making your money work for you i
think it's cool that's what i like about
this generation i feel a lot of people
that lose but at least they're losing
and having a lesson first hopefully
they're having less energy for me i
don't even get into it
yeah let me go and admit to some uh
ignorance and naivety i don't know if it
was based off of either lack of
education mentors the educational system
in general but the idea of having
this is gonna be basic as [ __ ] your
money work for you is a [ __ ] new
concept for me maybe i learned it like
four like you said uh 30s like four or
five years ago max
i was never
uh mentored and truly taught the value
and the avenues at which that could
happen in my 20s and or in the entire
education sector yeah dude i got my
[ __ ] financial aid uh when i was like
20 i don't know 21 22 i got like four
g's for the semester
i [ __ ] bought rims with that [ __ ]
they were dope though right look you
know it's that stimulus check kind of
guys like dude imagine i took that and
even invested it and that's actually
what happened though a lot of people who
got a lot of people who got this
pandemic money they [ __ ] pumped it
into crypto that's what i like and agree
about this generation or gen z or
everyone that's younger early 30s and
younger right is this never happened
before they're not as dumb but also we
didn't have accessibility we didn't have
robinhood yeah to go so we're considered
what is retail investors right like
everyday people yep um even if you got
millions of dollars if you're not a wall
street dude or a fund which is like a
collection of you know ass rich people
banks whatever
those guys are the ones that always had
the access to stocks and all this stuff
we're getting [ __ ] crumbs right but
now with things like robin hood and all
that and everything online we have
access to actually do investing in
whatever youtube too we got dudes like
graham steph and all the like meet kevin
and everyone teaching financial iq and
making it um
accessible i think that's the difference
by cardano and so that's sad but but
but no but to to really get into what
you're saying um what's so important too
is like when a lot of these people are
coming into crypto i think there's a lot
of just negativity coming in because of
all the [ __ ] meme coins that happens
right but if they were to understand
that all this stuff has actual utility
and use cases then it would be a
different story but they don't
understand that and dude for every like
i have like a bunch of crypto corners
right in my little group right my
patreon group
for every one of them they know three
people who say i don't buy crypto
because i can't i can't touch it there's
nothing tangible i can't feel it and so
or i'm too busy i i have too much going
on
if dude if you just put your stimulus
check into ethereum like when
everyone got on average at twelve
hundred dollar signature that's worth
like 35 thousand dollars today
back with me and joe we're doing money
masters we're telling people put the
money in the [ __ ] crypto yeah how
much was the ethereum back then it was
80 bucks dude it was it was at 100 100
bucks 120 max when we were doing it so
that's what i'm saying like like but no
one was talking about that dude
i had to do it a debate actually where
and joe was like facilitating this
debate between me and a guy who said he
he thinks crypto's a ponzi and i was
like hey i appreciate your perspective
this is great to have somebody who just
doesn't agree with me let's [ __ ] go
and and then like you know here we are
today i had never heard from that guy
again he probably killed himself
[Laughter]
but the point is like
i bet you he still believes it's a [ __ ]
yeah that's what i'm saying exactly some
people just lose he's waiting he's
waiting for it to crash exactly in the
game yeah he's a ruining cycle to end to
be the bear market i told him i know
people cashed out i told all you
millionaires it would end but that's
what happens all right when the market
is down yeah like if you always say you
kind of like well you kind of predict it
for the most part to me at least when
the market's down that's when everyone
is like cryptos [ __ ] i mean yeah
it's kind of like the dot-com bubble
right when
yeah it's a bubble like people were
super excited stocks and all these
things what people are paying for
is how much it can be not what it's
worth right now
yeah like even tesla like
right now are they worth the amount that
they are probably not they're banking on
the fact of all these projects of what
they will be five ten years from now so
that's basically what elon's charisma
but yes yeah if you zoom out on all of
it what he's saying is exactly right
right like it's an algorithmically it's
a going up like exponentially you can
see if you zoom in there's dips crazy
dips even 30 percent dips even 50 dips
but if you really zoom out the entire
thing has just been going up the whole
time it's a new technology being adopted
like when the microwave came out there
was a bunch of people who said i have an
oven why do i need a microwave that's
kind of suss i don't get it give me
cancer so it went up like this
exponentially over a couple of years it
was flat and then all of a sudden it
started the hockey stick up and that's
what's happening in crypto right now
you're in the middle of it if you're in
the united states of america not even 18
of the united states owns crypto you're
it's still early
the idea that you're late is stupid like
it's dude when you can start to use this
stuff like anthony uses this stuff me
and joe use this stuff bart uses stuff
kinda
and
i'm a noob i'm a wife yeah nick's a new
but you but you're kind of you're
interested in it and ryan you have
you've actually done well you've done
well
um you got some woo you're doing doing a
good job i always look at the token of
things
because
describe tokenomics to me
it's when you look at the the market
caps and you divide it by the volume
times the percentage and you get the
extrapolation
of the parabolic uh pass curve
thank you see i'm glad you have the
biggest house amongst all of us
it gives me a lot of hope
speaking of
speaking of parabolic curves and early
adoption and and raising everything
let's zoom out of just crypto let's talk
about just the idea of finance in
general anybody here see the new
inflation rate dude that just busted
no it's a nine is it nine technically
technically technically it's a
documented six point two percent for
2021.
uh but last month it was nine yeah so
they come with the yeah today's video is
brought to you by
draftkings draftkings the leader and
fantasy sports is putting you in the
center of action to get a chance to win
millions of dollars in total prizes
wow did you just say millions millions
of dollars in total prizes and it's a
super fun way to participate in the
football action that's coming up it's
pretty easy all you got to do is
download the draftkings app and enter
the football daily fantasy contests all
season long and they're giving out
millions in prizes millions millions but
you got to use the promo code off the
record it's easy to play too you just
draft nine players you could pick to
tight end the wide receiver quarterback
the quarterback and you just got to make
sure they got a salary cup of 50 000 and
the cool part is you get to enter to win
millions of dollars of prizes and
playing the game that you already like
wait did you did you remember to mention
that there's millions of prizes millions
of dollars of total prizes it's pretty
awesome because
you know it's not every day that you
could take a shot at this and i'm pretty
happy because like we get to have a lot
of fun this season yeah
anytime you add steaks to a sporting
event it's that much more fun it makes
it more intense but also it's something
that you can play with your friends and
yell at each other about because it just
makes it way more fun when there's
something to up the ante
so if you want a chance of making money
this season download the draftkings app
and use the promo code off the record to
get a chance at winning millions of
dollars in total prizes that's using the
promo code off the record by downloading
the draftkings app so if i were to if i
were to show you guys these ratings for
example just over a yearly chart what's
it mean anthony what's it mean okay so
think about it for
let's put it in simple layman's terms if
you add 100 okay in 2011 infra inflation
was three percent which meant that if
you had a hundred dollars chilling in
your bank if you had a hundred dollars
u.s dollar cash
three percent of it by the end of that
year or twelve month period would
literally pretty much burn based off of
raising price prices of everything else
everything else whether it be your
starbucks coffee a cup of coffee or
mcdonald's but how did it happen go
figure hey not to be too much of a
[ __ ] here i do have to beat the drum
a little bit me and this guy we're
talking about this during the pandemic
at the beginning of the pandemic we're
like they're inflating your money supply
you guys are about to get wrecked unless
you hold assets because they're printing
it like a [ __ ] and we're
guessing they're printing this stimulus
checks so in 2020 the inflation percent
was 1.4 percent
in 2021 which was just released it has
now risen to 6.2 and they just the if
the infrastructure bill that was just
signed right now they printed even more
money
and this is why like full circle right
like the whole reason why bitcoin crypto
all this stuff started was it's actually
an answer
to [ __ ] occupy wall street yeah read
the satoshi white paper like that's what
it's about and i remember back in the
day i was like all these people going
around with bongo drums protesting
they're so [ __ ] stupid dude if you
really want to make a change do
something effective and people got
pissed at me and i was like this is
what's a fact this is the effective
thing like if you want to fight against
the fed if you want to do something
different if you want to hold on to your
wealth this is the way you do it because
fiat which is dollars printed money all
this stuff right they could print it
whenever the [ __ ] they want they could
just buy it and just did it right now
you're like you know what let's just
print more let's print more and the more
they print the harder you got to work
for your freaking hours because the
dollar isn't worth as much as it used to
every [ __ ] year maybe it just made it
worse than ever why have a savings
account now worse than ever used to be
four percent i used to talk about losing
money by saving it yep
that's the craziest thing i don't it's a
hard concept to grasp yeah because like
when you look at money and the idea of
money you'd think it's kind of like this
like infinite thing and you don't know
where it comes from or what it like how
how the value is determined right and
when you speak of inflation it kind of
is intimidating it took me a while to
really understand what it is but then
my friends were saying like yeah if you
hold this money
you lose the value of it you lose it by
not using it you lose it by not
investing into it and i'm like what do
you mean and he goes well you know a cup
of coffee back in the day you know it
was like 25 cents right why do you think
that shit's like five dollars nowadays
you know it's like it's still a cup of
coffee or even houses like the house
that my mom lived in that i grew up in
in the 90s was like i think like 180
grand and now it's like 700 grand
because they keep printing [ __ ] money
they keep printing more and more and
more and more so based off of an
inflation calculator for anybody there
out there who enjoys numbers or
understands things
in
2010 so 11 years ago yeah 11 years ago
if you had a thousand dollars
that same thousand dollars in 2021
has a 26.8
cumulative rate of inflation which means
you would need to have
1268 dollars this year in order to equal
the same value of a thousand dollars 11
years ago so so what does the uh
simplify that what is again cumulative
rate of inflation 10 11 years has been
26.8 the the value of now versus then
like dollar for dollar so 1200 to 1 000.
so you lose 200 bucks 268 so yeah if
you're you know a minimum wage worker
guess what you're getting railed railed
and nobody's coming to save you they
keep on raising the amount of money that
they're printing every year yeah
inflation and taxes raises hourly wages
does it that's right and guess what cost
of goods goes up yeah cost of services
goes up cost of everything goes up but
you get left behind and that's by design
they don't give a [ __ ] about you it's
starting to happen too you go to certain
restaurants you see the the signs they
put up of sorry guys we have to increase
prices because of x y and z a lot more
and this is where sketchy conversation
comes in because of belief factors and
understanding of what you need to do
because there are times when people
complain about situations and focus on
the problem
versus accept and understand that
problems exist in life and then figure
out solutions that make sense in the
time or figure out opportunities exactly
so all i know is we just elected
democrats and their pro-worker and then
we have a democrat president who's
supposed to be a pro-worker and there's
nobody who's a pro-worker so it's
back-to-back same as it ever was same as
having republicans in charge so hello
hello we've been talking about this for
years guys it's time to wake up and
actually see they're taking your [ __ ]
life from you they're actually taking
away your power that's why people want
uh people say it's good to invest like
no matter how much money you make
because the economy is going to grow no
matter what it's never and there's
little dips and crashes whatever but it
goes straight line no matter what so if
you can take at least a percentage of
your money and you invest like in stocks
real estate crypto whatever you're going
to be able to grow with the economy and
that's what's important that's what
keeps you in the game because all the
companies that you buy into these prices
will continue to grow up but if you
invest in them then your money will grow
with them as they can continue to grow
and you can well you can't learn that on
your own you can't learn it from school
because they vote against that in school
they want to keep it as scrambled as
possible because turbo tax is one of
their biggest [ __ ] investors
congressionally you can look it up they
actually kill legislation to make it
easy for you to do your taxes because
they want it to be complicated because
they want to be able to benefit from it
so you know the outrage continues for me
because you can see the game laid out
before you but then unfortunately a lot
of people just don't see the game
because
they're inside of the machine getting
played speaking so speaking of the game
what's the end game profit yeah exactly
using us as cattle it's what's happening
what's the end game of like crypto then
how how are you gonna navigate using
this like newfound generational tool
that like 90 of americans don't use what
is the end game
so that it's actually practical and and
it has real world usage because most of
the people that i talk to about
kubernetes that don't dive into it and
understand it obviously we're already in
a realm they don't understand it how the
[ __ ] can they process hey look just
kryptoshiba on the blockchain that's
what people think right but actually
what's going on crypto is crypto is your
financial system that's being duplicated
on the blockchain decentralized so you
don't have to compete with the banks
because the banks are making 10
no matter what with your money at least
minimum every year they're making 10
you can make way more than that using
crypto right now using d5 elements that
exist that simulate the same way that
the banks use to make your to make your
money make more money except that you
actually get to participate you don't
have to so in layman's terms you are
your own bank correct
you're your own bank and what you invest
in is
part of your portfolio
and they can't do anything about it i
think that the beauty of it is they
can't
print more [ __ ] crypto exactly like
if you get bitcoin they can't print out
of nowhere like a handful of people
can't just get together and say let's
just print more nope
let's just print more and then
yeah devalue all the hard-earned money
that you saved up in your bank account
okay for those of you who are like yeah
but guess what they have so much money
they just buy bitcoin right now no they
can't because the last bitcoin gets
mined 100 years from now they can't
control the central power of bitcoin
because bitcoin's still being mined
so you're losing the concept of it
because you don't understand it and it's
not your fault it's everyone cnbc all
these guys they all can't wait to tell
you about how much of a ponzi it is how
much [ __ ] it is but there's more and
more politicians coming out showing uh
that they have already bought into it
for sure for sure there are there are
coins where they can just like mint and
make more ripple and yeah and that's
fair what's the term for that when they
[ __ ] the whole company just cashes
everything out red pool
pool yeah so so people there are things
like that so that's why you know
do your own d-y-o-r-d or do your own
resource the research is very very
important
uh but i will say that anytime we find
out about like politicians legislators
or anything like that that like maybe
stall or
inhibit right the the ability to like
have something progress but then they
have their own [ __ ] fat ass stacker
insider training stuff that is a
huge sign to invest a dead giveaway as a
[ __ ] gold ticket it was a scam what
the apple ceo publicly announced that
yesterday that he owns tim cook
has [ __ ] crypto even if apple doesn't
guys crypto's bad for the environment i
heard that six months ago and even
though it got completely debunked
because they use mostly hydroelectric
electric power because they can't afford
it to just plug it in the wall um i
still heard the fud so i don't care like
you see i'm saying like the fud works
really well because the people who are
haters
get to use that as power for a little
while and then unfortunately get wrecked
everywhere so fud is fear uncertainty
and doubt and i mean this has been in
stocks too but they do this to scare
people out of selling it not doing it
whatever so then people that want to buy
for a cheaper price can
[Music]
buy the dip as they say and being here
regardless of what may seemingly almost
seem like over saturation of the concept
of the topic of crypto it's we are in a
[ __ ] revolutionary generation i don't
think this type of information and the
uh brashness of how we talk about it is
actually we might have to do a full hour
yeah we should not available enough i
don't think enough people
understand the severity of
timing is everything think about timing
your [ __ ] relationships you know what
i'm saying like imagine that in your
financial lifestyle and relationships we
are in what has been notably the dot-com
internet style era and arc of our time
for our generation when we were [ __ ]
little kids in elementary and high
school and we didn't know [ __ ] about
investing into things like aol.com or
yahoo or
[ __ ] whatever and everybody made
millions off of something that was like
unbelievably how is the interwebs going
to be a thing i'm not going to buy
anything online yeah we are literally
so stupid yeah the internet of money is
happening the internet of money we are
web 3.0 the internet of money is
happening anybody who denies it is only
going to make those of us who believe in
it richer so thank you or they work at
western union good for them but but
that's part of what's going to happen
right so the power centers are going to
shift and all the people who live in
like latin american countries who use
western union to send money home the
western unions of the world are about to
get wrecked and they should they should
have gotten wrecked a long time ago
there's predatory fees preying on
migrant workers they can't wait to pray
on them and the the power is about to
get unleashed so that when you travel to
a like say you go to another country and
you are
subjugated to their prices like you have
to trade for their dollars you don't
have to do that anymore you can do it on
the blockchain and you can use your
phone use a qr code boom boom and you
can interact with a merchant nobody
else's permission it's one to one and it
trades your uh currency for their
currency using crypto on the back end
and nobody even knows what's happening
bitcoin is already the official currency
for el salvador right yeah a few
thousand yeah legal tender
i do want to
mention that like a lot of people like
you know
they're intimidated right because you
said like we don't grow up rich or
whatever and then we also have a false
idea of you have to grow up rich to
understand this stuff yes but i just
found out that you know that forbes 500
list of millionaires and
everybody pays to be on yeah sure pays
to be off but let me let me let me let
me tell you this though
only sevenish people
got their wealth from inheritance most
are first-time millionaires billionaires
most are people that grew up from humble
middle class regular kind of things you
know and they built their wealth over
time you know doing
normal boring [ __ ] that rockstar
billionaire stuff that's a real small
percentage so
that's that's everyday people like
everyday people has a chance to go out
there invest and do stuff but they don't
even open their minds to this
possibility because we all have it in
our thoughts like oh yeah you know like
you got to be rich or born rich to have
this like access but in reality most of
the people on that list 90 something
percent of millionaires they did it on
their own
so that means everybody watching you
know like you guys have the opportunity
yourself you don't you might not be a
[ __ ] billionaire i might not but you
know like but like the possibility of
becoming
upper middle class or doing well for
yourself that's totally possible so
possible
your banks are your banks are [ __ ]
you guys gotta be fired up you can
actually make sick multiples your banks
are who are collecting those multiples
and for themselves and they're giving
you the the bullshittiest returns you
could ever get i promise you you can do
much better didn't you send me some
certificate of deposit that was like
point five percent yes and the bank was
bragging about point zero five it was an
advertisement crypto corner with steve
green promise you change your life
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you